[Music]
today
is victory in europe day
millions rejoice in final and complete
victory after a war lasting nearly six
years
there was delirium euphoria you name it
that it was there amongst those crowds
piccadilly circus was just a vast
cheering sea of faces
it was a really a relief to know that
nobody was shooting us
again
we captured some village and
was announced while we were in this
village that the war had ended
somebody handed me a bottle of brandy i
saw very little
of the rest of the e day
[Music]
it's hard to explain how you can be
overjoyed
at something associated with a war
but the end of a war is a very precious
thing
on d-day itself i was on duty
and passing messages to the troops as
they were landing on the beaches
when they responded to the messages
i could clearly hear the sound of
gunfire
bombs falling men shouting
screams all manner of things
it was total mayhem
the mayhem of war
[Music]
my division that i was in we lost nine
thousand
killed wounded and missing
it's quite frightening to be an
observation tank
and see these tanks going up in flames
i can smell it to this day the smell of
death
and the gunfire continuous gunfire
[Music]
i want the generations to learn a lesson
why do people go and kill them one
another
you only live once
war is such a merciless operation
so that when the end comes yes
you're overjoyed it's over but
afterwards you calculate
the price that was paid for it